but first you might have seen that two
michigan state legislators met with the
president this afternoon at the white
house
the topic of conversation apparently was
election irregularities
in that state and it might not seem like
a very big deal politicians coming to
washington to talk to the head of their
party
it's pretty conventional it happens a
lot what you didn't know
is that it's now a felony a guy called
richard
primus wrote a piece for the liberal
blog politico
arguing that the republican legislature
should be prosecuted for their visit to
the white house
primus claims to have authority on legal
questions he says he works at the
university of michigan's law school
according to professor primus these two
lawmakers are quote
being visibly invited to a meeting where
the likely agenda
involves the felony of attempting to
bribe a public official
visibly invited what does that mean and
how exactly would he know that bribes
were offered in the white house
well of course he wouldn't know but it's
not like politico is going to fact check
a guy called
professor primus so they went with it
whatever
it's a crime to talk to trump everyone
knows that
that's an article of faith at msnbc the
rest of us in america have been laboring
under the illusion
that the first amendment still applies
in this country msnbc's legal experts
know better than that
supporters of unpopular presidents
deserve the lengthiest jail sentences
possible
at least 20 years they've read the fine
print on that and they've confirmed it
they went to yale law school yesterday
one of the channel's anchors a harvard
graduate you should know someone whose
blog was once unfortunately hacked by
racist time traveling cyber hooligans
explained the legal standard to viewers
as he remains holed up in the white
house like an end stage dictator
refusing to concede and frankly to just
go away
dissolving into unreality while the
republican party remains
silent and at this point it's hard to
argue with lifelong republicans like
stewart stevens
who are calling it sedition
sedition ladies and gentlemen this is
serious
sedition is punishable by decades in
prison
possibly death get the scaffolds ready
in the considered legal opinion of an
msnbc anchor quoting an unemployed
middle-aged political consultant that's
we could be looking at here
meanwhile democrats in congress are
suggesting the death penalty is on the
table bill pascrell representative from
new jersey tweeted this quote
tonight i'm calling for the eventual
prosecution of donald trump and his
enablers for their many
crimes against the united states traders
will swing
keep in mind that bill pasgrell is a
former mayor of a town in northern new
jersey
in northern new jersey but he's very
upset about the idea of corruption
in politics the new jersey mayor shocked
so much for democratic norms and the
peaceful transitions of power
they spent four years lecturing us about
there will be none of that they think
they won
now they want blood and by the way joe
biden hasn't spoken up against any of
this apparently he agrees with it
kamala obviously does what is this well
it's ugly and it's bad
it's also dangerous far more dangerous
than anything rudy giuliani could do in
a thousand press conferences
you'll notice that giuliani has not
called for the white house to round up
and imprison its political opponents he
never will call for that
republicans generally don't call for
that in fact they never do republicans
are
fascists the new york times tells us
what a hack newspaper
but who's eager to shoot the prisoners
it's not
right wingers it's the other side and it
always
is the other side always we've seen it
for the last four years
federal authorities many of them openly
hostile to the current administration
use the power of law to punish their
political enemies
and we saw it unfold right on television
they pursued process crimes like they
were dangerous felonies why'd they do
that
you know why they did it at one point
they sent a swat team and a tv
crew from cnn to raid the home of an
unarmed 68 year old man because
they claimed he had vital information
about russia collusion
actually told the judge that they
dragged him from his home
like he was running a fentanyl lab or
like you just stolen a tank from a
military base
and in the end after they humiliated him
destroyed his life
we learned what we already knew roger
stone wasn't part of any conspiracy
in the end the feds were forced to
downgrade the charges from agent of
vladimir putin to
he may have lied to congress once the
whole thing was a disgrace
but so-called liberals loved it they
clapped like seals at a water park
totally delighted by this man's
suffering
roger stone like donald trump is a
political con man
whose showman schtick has finally caught
up with him let me be the first to say
if you look up the word scumbag in the
dictionary you're going to see roger
stone's picture there
i am just so damn happy this guy is
indicted and arrested
[Applause]
bye bye baby that's what they say when
they come for you
it's sickening it ought to scare you it
ought to make you worry about what
happens when ghouls like that take power
in this country
the whole process is inevitable you
could have called it we've seen it
unfold all over the third world
only for like 100 years when you
politicize law enforcement and they have
when you prosecute the president's
advisors for lying
but ignore the obvious lying from say
the acting director of the fbi
the director of national intelligence
who lied under oath
you get what we're seeing now the same
people who complained about a
politicized department of justice are
now
salivating at the prospect of unleashing
the department of justice
on their political enemies and why
wouldn't they do that
kamala harris has been calling for it
for quite some time
if you become president if he was never
impeached would you want the department
of justice now that he is no longer a
sitting president
to go forward with those obstruction of
justice charges
i believe that they would have no choice
and that they should
yes there has to be accountability
there has to be accountability we're
keeping an ironing file but it's too big
we have to have accountability says the
politician who refused to submit to a
single press conference while running as
joe biden's running mate
the dishonesty is brazen and you can
begin to understand why so many
americans have lost their faith in our
institutions
including in our elections why because
the people managing them
are dishonest and incompetent our
leaders are demanding that we cower in
our homes they dine at the french
laundry
they're fantasizing about punishing you
for how you voted
but if you dare to notice any of this if
you dare to
notice what's happening you're the
dangerous lunatic maybe get the doj on
your trial
trail every once in a while the mask
does slip and they can see what's going
on
occasionally the media class tells the
truth it almost always happens by
accident
it happened earlier this month a pbs
correspondent whether that's someone
whose salary you help pay with your tax
dollars that's an
actual employee of actual state media
he admitted that the relentless focus on
jailing donald trump and his supporters
actually helps the media the media
understand their ratings will plummet
if they're forced to talk about anything
other than donald trump they have
nothing to say and of course they'll
never cover joe biden
they voted for joe biden so that's their
nightmare scenario
by continuing to hyperventilate about
donald trump for the rest of their lives
if possible maybe they'll stave off
irrelevance till the mortgage is paid
listen closely to this clip so you have
been president trump selling this idea
that there's a deep state conspiracy
theory against him that he's the number
one
victim in america so if he gets indicted
if he even goes to jail
he might sell that idea to the millions
of people who voted for him
and he might become even more powerful
and that's what the gop is really scared
about that's why you're seeing not that
many people stand up to him
it's just it's it's unbelievable on
every level
a correspondent who can't speak in a
grammatically correct sentence a
be the dishonesty of it framing this as
another clever conspiracy by donald
trump but of course it's about the media
they're narcissists
everything is about them of course they
want to keep talking about donald trump
they need to keep talking about donald
trump
and if that means sending people to
prison for the wrong political views it
is worth it